hoy en día Cuál es la situación de estos
colombianos qué dicen las autoridades al
respecto cuéntenos
bueno Bueno definitivamente el régimen
de excepción en El Salvador que ya tiene
a esta fecha después de 15 meses
capturados 70.000 personas ha servido
únicamente para la captura masiva más no
para hacer justicia un ejemplo de esto
es que incluso se capturan personas que
no son salvadoreñas es el caso de los
colombianos que tenemos por lo menos 20
colombianos capturados y lo sabemos por
testimonios de colombianos ya liberados
verdad debido a que pues no tenemos
documentación oficial o noticias
oficiales al respecto pero sí
testimonios de colombianos que ya están
en libertad y que pues nos han informado
que hay por lo menos 20 colombianos
dentro de las cárceles salvadoreñas
acusados de asociaciones ilícitas cuando
sabemos que en Colombia pues este
fenómeno no existe y por lo tanto el
hecho de venir como turistas o de
búsqueda de un trabajo por la narrativa
gubernamental que aquí el bitcoin por
ejemplo da fuentes de trabajo pues una
total mentira lo que los colombianos han
encontrado en El Salvador lejos de un
trabajo lejos de beneficios a raíz del
bitcoin es cárcel verdad para más de 20
colombianos en El Salvador a propósito
de esto que usted menciona Con qué
historias por ejemplo se ha podido
encontrar en qué condiciones llegaron
ellos al Salvador y cómo terminaron allí
correcto bueno recuérdese que la
propaganda gubernamental en el exterior
es que en El Salvador hay trabajo pues
ahora vivimos en un paraíso de
abundancia Gracias a que tenemos ahora
la moneda del bitcoin vigente en El
Salvador lo cual nosotros en nuestra
realidad lo vemos que es completamente
falso sin embargo esta narrativa digamos
que ha calado en personas de la región
como es el caso de los colombianos y
habla específicamente de por ejemplo el
caso de José Andrés Felipe Perdón
Andrés Felipe
Castañeda González ustedes lo pueden
observar aquí su esposa muy preocupada
pues hizo un Twitter verdad para
contactarnos a nosotros en la
organización donde ella denuncia en este
caso que su compañero de vida vino al
Salvador en búsqueda de un trabajo pero
lo que encontró fue cárcel de repente ya
no supo cerca de él verdad nada más que
estaba en prisión ya han pasado más de
seis meses que es pues el término que da
en este caso la acusación de
asociaciones ilícitas y a la fecha pues
no hay respuesta verdad a este
colombiano Al igual que a más de 70.000
salvadoreños se les ha negado su derecho
de defensa su presunción de inocencia el
derecho a un juicio justo y en ese
sentido Pues nos solidarizamos y para
nosotros los salvadoreños Es difícil
tener a tanta gente en prisión no saber
de ellos y que se nos ha denegado todos
estos derechos que estamos en el
territorio nacional como no es para una
persona desde Colombia por ejemplo desde
Guatemala desde Nicaragua verdad que
también hay personas captura das de sus
países ahora las personas que se
encuentran en esta situación que pueden
hacer al respecto
bueno nosotros hacemos un llamado
acercarse en este caso a las
organizaciones defensoras de Derechos
Humanos lo primero que tenemos que hacer
es presentar un adeas Corpus ante la
sala de lo constitucional donde exigimos
la libertad y la exhibición personal de
estas personas ilegalmente capturadas
para que comparezcan de manera inmediata
ante un tribunal o solicitar medidas
cautelares por supuesto denunciar ante
la fiscalía general de la república Y
ante los Derechos Humanos para que
también pues el estado salvadoreño tenga
una condena puesto que no es justo que
en nombre de en este caso tener terminar
con las pandillas también sea costa del
sufrimiento de inocentes